bonjour je suis pas première dommage non
il ne serait pas première mais vous êtes
première dans mon coeur c'est alors ça
change très vite elles savent à une
annonce mais ça change à ces bateaux là
tu vois tu es là je t'explique ici et là
les biens de lendemain tu es une merde
les gens te jettent des pierres un an
mais je te le dis cette émission ça va
très vite
oui alors j'ai pensé à vous parce que je
sais que vous adorez le slam mois ci en
libye parce que vous êtes un amoureux
des mots le slam l'émission non cela me
la musique
ah oui cela mais quoi siano mais quoi
ouais comme grand corps malade
ouais ben alaoui et hier j'ai regardé la
grande librairie je sais pas si vous
avez le temps de le voir la grande reine
avait travaillé en ce moment la grande
librairie garde en replay peut-être
vraiment que moi je manque à langon
libre c'est à quelle heure cette affaire
mais c'était en ben oui la grande
librairie et j'ai lu basse et g2 vous
connaissez l'animateur l'anima bien sûr
alla mongrain du bourg c'est qui le gars
déjà j'aime bien me neil buhne elle
françois henri vinay je connais les
prénoms des gens moitié chez françois je
l'appelle à l'eau françois qui suppose
une nouvelle orsenna
bah voilà exactement l'émission était
vraiment pour vous parce que erik
orsenna de l'académie française a rendu
un hommage de sorte d'hommage au slam de
grand corps malade et s'est lancé dans
l'aventuré du slam je me rappelle quand
j'étais à l'académie française
erik orsenna avait des larmes aux yeux
avec eux en kit académie française quand
on a oui quand on meurt normal oui mais
j'ai une dérogation que je connais
rectorat oui mais attends d'accord vous
l'écrivez vous serez bien parce que moi
c'est mon maître lui parce qu'il ya des
potes mais lui c'est beau m vous écrivez
que vous aimeriez cela mais ceux ci une
république réussi est un territoire où
ne résonne plus cette phrase maudite la
culture c'est pas pour moi
la culture c'est pas pour moi abdelmalik
comment cela
d'abord j'ai regardé cette émission hier
et je me disais qu'est-ce qui serait
capable de me coller sur un auteur ou un
truc comme ça aujourd'hui c'est
impossible
vous avez été super fort avec le livre
de philippe viannay d'avril avait épaté
oui donc je me suis dit aujourd'hui je
vais encore vous testez alesi par
exemple qui a écrit ferry pour une autre
fois ceni pour une autre fois féerique
karine ferri pour un autre mois ferry
pour notre voie jeu attendez je
l'entendais j'entends des bruits
bizarres temps des deux minutes je
reviens
[Musique]
toi
même si ça va de mal en pis alors on est
on avait un petit problème il ya trois
personnes qui ont failli se noyer
comment comment tu t'appelles ouais
c'est louis louis et toi ou sfr dit non
et toi nationalité sedin céline alors
écouter et ben j'arrive mais ça va tout
va mieux merci
[Applaudissements]
si moi j'avais une intervention j'ai
même pas pris la brûler vous me
demandiez suffisamment mairie pour une
autre fois qui en effet l'auteur sait
pas louis ferdinand céline
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]